all right so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna I'm gonna start out I
I have a few slides here so whatever
kind of fun I want to talk a little bit
about the case for markets and
intellectual property which is really
the argument I make we were just talking
about the fact that there's a there's a
bunch of different strands going on in
copyright law in theory right now and
you have a number of of companies and
people and artists are involved in the
creation of intellectual property and
they have a point of view about their
ability to control and decide how what
they do should be exploited how it
should be how it should be used and how
they should be able to market it and how
they should be able to profit from it
there is another whole strand that has
to do and there's the whole series of
arguments that I think began to come up
actually for a very long time but really
began to bubble up I think probably 10
or 15 years ago concerned about the
breadth of intellectual property law
concerned about the question of how far
should a copyright go what should we be
able to protect what should you know
when should I have to go get a license
from an architect who's building is in
the background how much at a trademark
owner be able to continue to protect
their trademark in various context and
I'm not really going to talk too much
about those issues even though that's a
lot of where this debate started and
frankly we will talk at the end I put up
some talking points but I'm happy to
talk about whatever issues in this
general area you want to talk about
there are a lot of very interesting
issues to me and others around the
periphery of copyright many people are
still gonna be surprised to find out
that even as part of a big company and
as a consumer and as a guy who loves
technology and loves gadgets and all the
interesting things that are happening on
the internet I kind of agree with I
actually care a lot about fair use I
care a lot about having the breath to
create our stuff and to sell it without
having to get undue licenses without
having to get permissions we care a lot
about those issues and we are probably
not as much in disagreement with some of
the people who you know consider
themselves innovators and we'll talk
about what I mean by innovation what we
really care about and what we're really
focused on in our business right now is
the exact copy the copy where there is
no new creativity there is no new
innovation except maybe you know ways to
to distribute it but no real creativity
innovation added in the content itself
it's about the exact copy it's about our
movie that we spent 200 million dollars
to make a market that you find for free
the next day on a site that's based in
Hong Kong or the Ukraine or Vanuatu or
some of these places that's the concern
nevertheless they come in tension with
one another because protecting those
what we would consider markets for IP
requires at the periphery some dealing
with a bunch of balancing kinds of
issues and I think that's where the
excitement is right now and that's maybe
where we're on a different position
where with some others particularly in
the Academy but I think you know our
experience is that we really trust in
negotiations to deal with these issues
much more than we do
regulation or with the ability of people
to could take and exploit content
without without paying for it where I
start really is with copyright and free
speech copyright is and free speech are
both embodied in the Constitution
actually copyright came first when the
Constitution was adopted there was
actually a provision which granted
Congress the power to grant people
exclusive rights in the works of their
writings and discoveries so the basis of
patent copyright law is right there in
the Constitution a couple of years later
when the Bill of Rights was enacted the
very first amendment obviously dealt
with the question of free speech I don't
think these two issues are in tension
really and there's been a lot of theory
really over the last more than 200 years
talking about copyright which encourages
people to speak it encourages people to
come forward and and write and get their
thoughts out and participate in the
dialogue and and have a way to to
finance that activity originally it was
newspapers and books and later all kinds
of other activities that was a
considered a core First Amendment value
encouraging the freedom of the press
meant providing the freedom of the press
and individuals with the opportunity to
benefit for
their work and that's really the point
here copyright industries just to give
you an idea of the size of the business
that we're talking about in the most
recent numbers which were 2008 figures
were 889 billion dollar business
that's the media and software it's games
it's it's music it's all kinds of
businesses that depend on copyright
we're not even talking about the patent
business now we talk about the copyright
business is six point four percent of
the country's gross domestic product and
they talk about industries that relate
to copyright being a one and a half
trillion dollar business it's something
that matters a lot these are businesses
that pay taxes they're businesses that
employ a lot of people they're
businesses that that that foster
creativity the the notion of having the
right to decide whether your work
whether your activity in the
intellectual property area is entitled
to protection is actually baked right
into document called the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights this is the
document that created the United Nations
and you'll see right there the first is
a First Amendment value it's the ability
to participate in the dialogue to
receive information and the second is
the right to that you have a moral
fundamental right to protect anything
scientific literary artistic productions
of which you are the author again right
there
if you make it if you write it if you
create it if you invent it you're
entitled to profit from it somebody
shouldn't be allowed to take it from you
copyright drives the sale of a lot of
these interests nobody ever watched
nobody ever bought an iPod to look at it
no maybe a few people people buy iPods
because there's interesting software
that runs on it there's music that plays
on it the Kindle is to see books it's
not about the Kindle copyright drives
innovation and all these consumer
product markets people are using them
because they love the stuff that they
can participate in with them these it's
an industry that actually when we talk
about innovation and we'll talk a little
about some ways in which our industry
and our company particularly in
particular participate in innovative new
businesses and online businesses but
when you talk about innovation some
people try to take that debate and refer
to businesses that rely on on an
unlicensed IP and say hey you know this
is the kind of thing that's innovative
and this is the kind of thing that
having a licensed IP would prevent and I
would say that a more sustainable kind
of innovation really is about the kind
of innovation that you get when if you
make an investment you get an
opportunity to get a return
and so the entertainment business the
movie business the ability to invest in
movies and get a rate of return develops
things like digital digital motion
picture screens three-dimensions new
cameras a host of all kinds of things in
the movie business and a television
business again there been huge amounts
of innovation those are all funded by
the view that somebody's going to engage
in big coordinated activity invest a lot
of money and start big labs and design
and invent things that they're gonna get
a rate of return on they're gonna get
ready to return on because they're
useful in a movie business that's
vibrant in a programming business that's
vibrant again some just some interesting
statistics about the size of the
business and the importance to the
economy the next slide I think is
obvious to everybody living in this age
piracy is a problem right we have new
networks it's easy to move content
around it's a lot easier than it used to
be you know when I was starting out
copying VHS cassettes if any remember
what those are you know you can copy a
movie it would take a day or at least a
few hours and and you could pass them
around to your friends it wasn't such a
big problem now you know things like
rapidshare megaupload other things could
make a copy of a movie available to
millions of people more or less in an
instant
broadband connectivity is is high it's
certainly going to go higher the speed
of what constitutes broadband is growing
very quickly and lots and lots of
consumer devices are taking advantage of
new capabilities cheaper storage in
order to make copies and in order to
facilitate new ways to use content so as
a result there is a there is a huge
increase
in the ability of people to engage in
unlicensed content distribution I do
like to point out that Viacom is an
innovator I wouldn't really talked about
the begin about what Viacom is Viacom's
businesses are really twofold today
we've been on a bunch of different media
related businesses but right now we're
in the movie business we own Paramount
Pictures and we are in the media
networks business we own a company
called MTV Networks you all know MTV and
the MTV Networks business includes
brands that you've all heard of like
Nickelodeon and vh1 Comedy Central
Country Music Television spike and some
others and it also includes a number of
new businesses which are some of that is
about distributing those businesses
online and so it is about entirely new
businesses so we may have played the
game rock band which is from a company
that we don't cut all harmonics and
which just recently came out with a
Beatles version and it is a really cool
and different and digital way to
experience music so just to just some of
the kinds of things we license our
content to Netflix Netflix is a non
cable way to get content we we license
our content to Hulu which I'm sure
you've all watched a way to get
television shows on your computer
instead of on your television set we
license through Apple you can get our
shows through on PlayStation on mobile
devices were the number one programming
service on Verizon Wireless we have a
bunch of sites we have something called
flux which is a social networking site
that goes across a lot of our brands so
so we're we are we are in 50 countries
25 languages we have seven or 50 movies
that are available for download owned or
rental or both online we're very much
taking advantage of the new business
opportunities that are available to us
online and very interested in the kind
of ways that we could be you know your
needs and the needs of consumers by
taking advantage of all this has to
offer at the same time as we talked
about a huge amount is available
pirated sites different industries have
done some studies some of those are here
the movie industry it's done a
calculation that they lose eight billion
dollars a year to piracy that's not just
online piracy but those are
sophisticated numbers that's not just
saying that's not just adding up the
number of copies that are downloaded and
saying each one is worth X number of
dollars these are done with surveys in a
number of countries and talking to
people about the offset for promotion
talking to people about how much of
that's additional viewing versus
substitutional viewing and try to do the
best estimates that people can so
they're fairly sophisticated numbers the
other studies are done the same way it's
about three billion dollars in games
it's growing very fast some of you have
been on PSP PSP is open to pirated
copies that has been a real problem for
Sony in music it's a 12 and a half
billion dollar problem certainly the
pirated music is a much bigger business
than then licensed music at this point
and there's a lot of cost shifting going
on in that business big companies like
ours end up paying a lot of money for
music rights because that's what's
subsidizing that's what's that's what's
supporting the music business now so the
licensing of music for television shows
the licensing of music for cable and the
like is supporting music and and
software their estimate is over five
million dollars lost just to give you I
just did a couple slides to show you how
easy it is to pirate I would be
surprised if all of you hadn't seen some
of these or all of them but on YouTube
for example we recently just did a
screenshot you can see a movie that's a
reasonably expensive picture and
recently in the stores or I guess in
this case not so recently Bowling for
Columbine you can see even though
YouTube has a 10-minute limit somebody
just put up the entire movie in in 12
parts we've seen actually full-length
movies in a single part available on
YouTube and other user-generated content
sites you can see from this that market
wire's is is is paying money for an
advertisement against an unlicensed clip
as well somebody's putting a clip down
here it looks like iTunes at the bottom
of the page and so that London Isis clip
is generating revenue but not any
revenue for the people who produced the
material it Chinese add therefore any of
you who reads Chinese but you can see
that some of the sites are difficult to
find in jurisdictions where enforcement
is very hard
here you see an episode of South Park
available on to go and even legitimate
companies are getting in on the act
real DVD came out with a product last
year it's been subsequently and joined
by a court in California but real DVD
said you know will will break the
encryption on a DVD and allow you to
copy it to your hard drive which is a
feature I'd love and in fact our
industry now is realizes that this is a
feature people love and are selling DVD
some of you may have seen them called
second session DVDs where you buy the
DVD and it has a digital copy that you
can copy over your hard drive of course
you can download these things to your
hard drive and our concern really wasn't
around real DVD letting you copy your
DVD to your hard drive our concern was
that you can go to Netflix and pay $9 a
month
and copy as many DVDs as you want
essentially for free and they were
enabling that business as well so what's
happening to piracy and why are we so
concerned it's moving from peeta peeta
streaming many of you have experience
with p2p p2p is slow especially with
movies it can take you a few days
there's a longer version of this
presentation that shows how it works I
don't need to do that but what you do
see is that it's now moving to a
streaming environment because as a
consumer that's a much better way to
watch a movie if you can find it on an
online site where you can just stream it
to your computer you can watch it right
away you don't have to wait for the
thing to download it is peer-to-peer for
video seems to be on the wane the
numbers are actually significantly
declining but it's getting picked up
very quickly among among these streaming
sites a lot of people are starting to
use video sharing sites now you know
some of that's a lot of that's
legitimate low that's UGC know
all nineteen percent is pirated but the
pirate percentages are very high
and the other thing that's very
concerning and is that lots of TVs are
being connected the internet now I say
concerning it's a great opportunity TVs
connect to the internet or something
that we're working with Hulu on the
Internet
some of the Downloads own services and
the like are gonna be great things but
it's also an opportunity for piracy to
become more of a mainstream activity
show you just a couple of the businesses
that are built on this rapidshare
rapidshare has a business model that's
very interesting you upload content to
rapid share and make it available to
your friends and the more people who
come to watch your content the more
money they'll pay you or they'll give
you gifts so they're paying for that
viewership the way they make their
business model is charging both
subscriptions and selling ads and you
just do the little business while it's
not a bad little business this is not a
guy in this garage you know it's not an
end user who's making a mistake but we
figure anywhere from 15 to 200 million
dollars a hundred thirty five million
dollars of profit a year because it's
very handy to be able to have a media
business when you don't have to pay for
the content the sites are looking better
this looks like a real site it some
people a meaningful number of people
would come across the site and not
realize that it was a pirated site you
can see they're very proud of the fact
that they have ten thousand movies of
premium quality so it's just a couple if
you if you scour around and use the
search engines you can find an awful lot
why does it matter and should we be
doing anything about it as I mentioned
you know making one movie these days and
distributing a movie on average cost a
little more than a hundred million
dollars some pictures cost more than two
hundred two hundred fifty million
dollars and there's a market for
big-budget motion pictures not all not
all content is going to be big motion
pictures and there's lots of new stuff
that cost less lots of new things that
become available but consumers like
big-budget motion pictures they like
high production value television
in order to make it you have to have an
opportunity to generate the revenue from
it and therefore you have to gotta
transact with it with a customer and
piracy undermines that it keeps the
communication from customers to
providers from happening it keeps things
that people would like to see from being
things that they can see because the
money chain from users to producers
begins to disappear it harms the
consumer experience a lot of money is
spent on trying to and a lot of time and
effort and creativity is better trying
to create an experience when you're in
the theater watching a television set
that grabs you draws you into the story
that makes you really love the
characters it rubs the show sometimes it
works but with a consumer begins to
experience the content of the show in a
bad way that could hurt your brand we
talked about the economic numbers and
beyond that you know and I think a lot
of people have seen particularly the
music space that when people begin to
think of things as free they don't value
them in the same sort of way they begin
to think it's a free kind of thing and
it's it's not a thing that is a value
whatever the long-run that may be the
biggest issue at all there is something
you can do about it I'll give him one
example in a user-generated content
space we've been working with companies
that are doing things called filtering
now two or three years ago it was a
little harder to do some of these things
have existed for for a long time
interesting the technology really began
to develop for different reasons than
content matching in the case of one of
the technologies we use for example the
intent was they were it was an automatic
way to tell of a somebody's commercial
was running on on a radio station or
television station and they were using
that as a way to just report back to
advertisers that they got what they paid
for some of them work better than others
some of them are audio only some of them
are video and they are able to batch the
video file but what they do is they give
you an automatic way to tell whether the
content is licensed content or not
licensed content and then in some cases
they let you do some different things
with them so for example YouTube hit now
has a
as a filter built-in it matches on the
video file as well as the audio file so
it helps us prevent we've been trying
very hard to avoid the mashup as I
talked about or things that evolve new
creativity so we make sure that the
Clint the clip as best as we can is
really just an exact match of our
content we we try to match both on audio
and video or else we have people look at
it to make sure that that it's really
not a fair use issue and and then we
could make decisions and they just
populate a table say okay the business
content that needs to come down this is
content that can stay up or a third
category of this content you can run an
ad against and and then will participate
in the ad revenue and so a lot of
content companies are working with that
model and it's interesting it's an
interesting model that lets you let you
control your content or make a decision
that you're willing to participate in
this business opportunity and receive
some some reward just an example of a
recent one so some of you may have
noticed when when we ran the MTV Music
Video Awards in September the there was
a clip where Kanye West came up and told
everybody that who should have won the
award and immediately lots and lots of
clips were posted to to YouTube and
other places in 2008 we had 21 point 3
million views of the VMAs on sites that
weren't our own and at that time we
weren't licensing any user-generated
content sites and only 16.8 to our own
so the sites on the Left were making
money they were selling ads
they were generating traffic to other
parts of their sites but paying nothing
for the content that we produced this
year we still had 19 point 2 million
views that were not us but this year we
had 35 and a half million that were us
the feature was as the Video Music
Awards were running we were loading our
content into filters and the sites were
coming down and frankly the most useful
piece of it was that we were training
users that the clips were up you could
get them they were embeddable they were
linkable you could include them in your
email you could include them in your
blog but
on our sites and so it was an
opportunity for us to participate in the
benefit of what we were spending the
money to produce so YouTube comes up and
people really begin to to focus on
what's a reasonable thing to ask a
user-generated content site to do and as
I mentioned kind of at the beginning
we're really in both pieces of this
space we run user-generated content
sites we like we like the creativity and
the aspects of it we have shows that are
based on user-generated content we like
participating with our community and
developing the creativity at the same
time what we can't do or is to allow the
user to enter content sites to benefit
and profit from the content that they're
not paying for now that's imperfect we
can't we can't be perfect about it and
we can't expect everybody to find every
clip of material that's up on their site
and we certainly don't want to be in
litigation with a lot of people over
these issues we want to come up with a
way that everybody can coexist in a
world that seems fair so there was a
negotiation that took place among a
number of media companies and a number
of user-generated content sites and we
developed something called the UGC
principles and the idea was use the
technology that's available as best as
you can and everybody's going to agree
that's going to be good enough and the
world will continue to develop and
you'll continue to develop these things
this these principles are available I
think they may you may have seen copies
of them as part of the reading material
the reason I think they're really
interesting these because it shows that
there are possibilities of working on a
consensual solution and working your way
towards practical results what happens
when people sit down in the room and
they say this is what we can do and this
is what we need to do is you can work
some things out that that really work in
other environments we talked a little
bit about megaupload and rapidshare
their real interest is not in coming up
with a rational solution their interest
is in monetizing content and they're
unwilling to come to the table and work
on unreasonable solutions graduated
response this is a you've started to
hear about this perhaps and
France and other parts of the world the
idea is that we don't want to be suing
in users it's expensive and it's painful
and it feels like bullying there are end
users who have legitimate answers to
things there are and users who've been
spoofed there are any users don't
understand and so the idea is to try to
help educate people about what's allowed
what's not allowed and to begin to
impose a sanction that's more
proportional to the harm and so I think
there was a feeling the record companies
were big on suing end users there was a
feeling you know average people with
average resources we're finding
themselves on the other end of lawsuits
with very expensive resources and
unlimited very expensive lawyers and
unlimited resources and it felt like
terrorism we need to move back we need
to move to a system that feels more in
balance than fairer and so there's a lot
of discussion going on about whether we
can come up with a system where the end
users name is never disclosed to a
copyright owner but ISPs pass along
notices people can't tell when people
participate in peer-to-peer networks who
they are what IP addresses are
participating in the network not their
names but what the IP address and began
to look for non-judicial ways to deal
with that issue and as well for ways to
people to challenge it so I think part
of a rational system and part of the
learning is there ought to be some non
court way to deal with an ombudsman or a
mediator who says we'll wait a second
you know there was a problem with my
computer it wasn't my computer it was
spoofed or something else yes I got four
notices but I don't get it
but some ways that feel fair to people
to resolve disputes and to make sure
that the the issue is not overbearing it
is a it is a difficult thing because
this is a very same people who are your
customers and the people that you care
most about making happy need to be
treated with respect and at the same
time there's really no other way to deal
with the problem other than their
dealing with the need to to move viewing
into licensed context so I pretty much
just talked about about this slide so
let me talk a little bit about some of
the
about copyright as I started out people
talk about copyright prevents creativity
and locks up knowledge that it prevents
innovation that it's just for big guys
and it's not for four for the average
person the technical protection expands
the rights beyond copyright I'm going to
talk about a few of these in the next
few slides and then at the end I'm gonna
kick it open for people to ask questions
and let's just to gauge in a dialogue
one of the most popular things in the
world is to say that things ought to be
free it has sold a lot of books a lot of
copyrighted books yes it's true free is
a good thing actually even some even
some national elections although you
know Chris Anderson's book was free for
a month online and then now you have to
pay for it
and what's interesting is actually
although it sells books Christian arsons
book was not about free at all he talked
about free and it got a lot of play bed
the title and maybe the relief we
actually read the book what he talks
about is that free as part of a business
model and that free works when it is a
way to provide a sample it works as a
way to get people a part of something
and then there may be a pay model behind
it it may be a way to tease somebody
into watching an advertisement giving
things away has always been a part of a
commercial enterprise people have always
allowed samples they've always provided
free stuff as a way to sell stuff along
the way get you to come to something so
they can put a billboard next door to it
that's what Chris Anderson's book
focuses on it focuses on a wide variety
of creative models along those lines
free as a way to promote and I'm not
going to get into the details about
these other books it was really just a
highlight
have you and okay I mean James spoils
argument that's another conversation we
could talk about that later if you want
it is true there is absolutely no
question that copyright this is to
counter James Boyles argument copyright
is not necessarily if you asked a
consumer would they rather pay or would
they rather it be free every one of us
says we like free you know and it
definitely feels like if you want to
charge for something they people
throughout the term it's anti consumer
and in fact when you really get into it
it seems to me that what the consumer
really wants at the end of the day is
the opportunity to deal with as many
possible vendors at as many possible
price points and many business models as
possible but they want the product to be
created in the first place and they want
people to be motivated to create it to
serve them and are willing to pay a fair
price or watch an ad or whatever it is
that ultimately generates that content
we use a you know there's a the analogy
is if you said milk should be free
everybody would say that's a great idea
when all the farmers stop producing milk
they'd say maybe that wasn't such a good
idea and the same thing really applies
with respect to copyright let me talk a
little bit again about the theme about
how copyright in the First Amendment and
how copyright and and and the users
really play together and and these these
issues are really important in the sense
of dealing with some of the criticisms
first off the fair use right or the fair
use defense is a key part of copyright
the point is is that there is a place at
which the rights of an owner of
copyrighted material need to be limited
because now they're infringing on free
speech as opposed to adding to free
speech so somebody who writes and you
guys are probably talked about this in
more detail I'm going to talk about it
now somebody who writes a review of a
movie somebody who takes a little piece
of something that you all know about
that's copyrighted materials want to
refer to it but say something else say
something different something that's not
just repeating the work and using the
same word
and interfering with the market for it
but somebody who's doing something
transformative with it and making
something new and different has a right
to do that and that's a very important
part of making the system work second
and this is really important as well is
that copyright unlike patent and and a
lot of places like Boyles book among
others where they you will see people
deliberate who don't like copyright for
whatever reason deliberately combined
copyright and patent and it's a real
mistake neither say IP it's all the same
thing
copyright does not protect ideas it's
right there at the beginning of the
Copyright Act copyright is designed to
encourage people to put their ideas out
there what copyright does it gets you to
speak it gets you to write in the
newspaper it's encourages people to take
those ideas and use them up in different
ways
now it's an oversimplification because
figuring out where the idea ends and the
expression begins it's not simple and
lots of Court decisions have been based
on that particular issue but if you're
not taking from the expression of the
idea and you're taking the concept
you're absolutely allowed to use it and
that's part of what makes copyright work
we rely at Viacom on fair use every day
I am NOT an exponent the copyright
should be huge and should go as far as
it Picasa could possibly go so we talked
about my issue is about the exact copy
so we have a show tosh.o so we may have
seen it on MTV where he spends a lot of
time talking about user-generated
content and what's cool and what's out
there
vh1 uses clips from video and creates
the show called best week ever it relies
very heavily on fair use there's a fun
one we litigated this issue to me more
it this this is probably before a lot of
you guys were born maybe not quite but
but this cover was a very very famous
cover where to me more was pregnant and
Vanity Fair ran it on their cover and so
a few years later we came out with this
movie Naked Gun 33 and a half with
Leslie Nielsen in the same post and we
got sued by Annie Leibovitz as the
photographer and we want this is clearly
fair use
nobody nobody bought that instead of
that anymore a picture right exactly
exactly it's a good example of fair use
it's also a good example of how how we
how we use it we care about this stuff
and and the reason why you did this of
course is because at the time everybody
remembered the picture so it was funny
and if we hadn't used the picture if we
had come up with some other pose it
would not have made the reference and so
this is a classic example of parody
which is an example of fair use this is
a complicated slide I'm not going to
cover all of it the point that I want to
make as people make concerns about
digital rights management now why do
they people just like Detroit's benefit
for a number of reasons one of them is
that the it a lot of it has been really
bad so a lot of it has really affected
the way you want to use things even in a
license terms they you know your license
disappears when you're supposed to have
it there's a lot of problems with early
implementations of DRM the point I
wanted to make with this slide is that
digital rights management also enables
different business models and in the
movie context in particular they total
rights management is enabling us to do a
lot of a lot of cool stuff so for
example if you go to iTunes you can rent
a movie now it used to be you had to
download it to own but now you can rent
it so we can charge three dollars and
you can have it for I think the business
rules now are 24 hours of watching but
you can keep it under computer for 30
days we can charge three dollars for
that without DRM we'd have to charge for
to own the movie or one could say we
have to charge for the right to pirate
the movie it enables us to experiment
with different ways that consumers might
want to like the material and a lot of
those are at lower price points and so
what it does is it gives us the facility
to experiment innovate with different
ways that people interact with material
and come up with an economic model
that works for the production of the
movie but also but also may expand the
audience and make it more affordable
some of the other things that we do
using digital rights management epics is
up is a really cool new application
epics launches at the end of October
it's a new movie service it has
first-run movies in some ways it's just
like HBO or Showtime you can get it on
your cable system but what you can also
do is you can get it on your computer
and if you get the cable subscription
the computer service is free and this is
called an authenticated model and
there's a server on the other end that
that knows you're a cable subscriber and
authenticates a number of devices and
you can watch your movies on your on
your computer you could be in a hotel
room somewhere or you know somewhere
else you could hook a computer up to
your television set there's nothing that
prevents you from doing that at your
friend's house that's all included
within your subscription
it's another business idea that's
enabled by the use of digital rights
management there's the rock band game on
the bottom left we sell songs that you
can play on play with your with your
musical instruments and those songs are
are limited to the particular box that
enables us to settlement a dollar
ninety-nine despite the effort that goes
into creating them and that's a that's a
new business model we're available on
things like Hulu and xud as we talked
about and that that really takes me to
the end of the presentation part of this
and really kicks things open for some of
the kinds of questions that they're
already copyright and I threw these up
there but I'm really happy to talk about
whatever else people are interested in
talk about